you've got these two ideas skillet now
let's do scientifically yeah hands up
hands up how many of you know how to
write scientific notation already
haven't seen it before like in science
it's it's tricky
now my question to you is why son why
isn't it like historic notation or or
mathematical notation like why is it
scientific notation scientists came up
with scientists use it why why would
they come up with their own way of
writing numbers pain isn't it like what
okay sir yes my mind's scienter notation
maybe you want to drop this down
underneath scientific notation makes
some numbers much easier to write and
what weird I'll give you some examples
by I'll give you some examples in a
second okay so let's think of science
think of sighs give me some topics in
science my body biology what else
physics chemistry okay let's take a few
notes right um let's go with chemistry
and chemistry what do they study they
studied like atoms and elements right
now huh
how BIG's an atom it's so small like you
know you you can't see it with the human
eye it's tiny no I I actually don't know
that oh maybe someone could look it up
but I take it like what's it what's a
centimeter
that's 0.01 meters right that's too big
that's that's not an atom right 0.001
meters that's a millimeter still too big
that's right it's going to be something
like you know this heaps and heaps and
heaps of zeros here I didn't even know
if that's enough it's something like
that okay but the point is it's very
small atoms very small and you guys know
atoms are the smallest things are they
like what's smaller than
you've got you've got like what's what's
eatin at him
there's electrons around this is the
stuff inside the nucleus that's even
smaller than that okay so you got you've
got small numbers okay maybe I should
say you got really small but at the same
time he's hiding really small numbers
right what else do you look at like
astronomy boy yeah astronomy is a topic
in science isn't it
and what kinds of things are there
ensuring this planet but planets are
small right what else is there in space
this stars right what's bigger than a
star yeah
galaxies right how BIG's a galaxy it's
not like one big not not a hundred
meters it's not even millions of meters
right yeah that's right we have to make
up new units to to say how big these
exactly see out really small numbers and
then you got really big numbers right
it'd be a pain if you had to write all
the zeros so instead scientific
notations uses these IDs so you don't
have to